Hello everybody, do another Zoom call, welcome.
I do my best to answer your questions.
It is the 8th of October, 2025.
Now everybody's having a great fall.
Let's get to your questions.
Make sure that if you're new to this, that you can chat in your questions
in the chat box there.
So feel free to think of something.
Talk to send in or if you think of something along the way,
you can chat in.
We have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 questions that were submitted.
So we will get started.
A reminder to look at the announcement.
There wasn't any new announcements this week.
But I do remember, say, if there's any new announcements,
remember to look at those.
Okay.
The first question.
Is it possible that I am doing too much soda?
Well, it's always possible that we do too much of anything,
except maybe prayer.
But yes, too much of a good thing can be a bad thing.
So I don't know how much soda this person will ask the question is doing.
But I remember several years ago I had a gal who was doing
3, 30-minute sauna sessions a day trying to help her detox
and she was sweating profusely on each sauna.
Is that too much?
Well, I don't know.
I mean, every human being is different.
So I wouldn't even say that there is a number that we can assign to
what is too much soda and how we can define that.
Everybody's different.
I suppose it partly depends.
You know, how much do you weigh?
And, you know, are you losing weight doing the soda?
Are you losing too many electrolytes doing the soda?
Certainly, you can't argue that there's people that work outside
in the Southern climate in the heat and are sweating like a pig for eight hours a day.
Lane block or something like that.
You can't say, oh, is that too much sweating?
Well, the whole purpose of a sauna is to create a, you know, a detox portal
through your skin by you sweating.
So can you do that too much?
Well, you could, you know, end up dehydrated because you're losing too many of your
electrolytes so that you can't hold your water.
So if you are doing too much soda,
you got to make sure that you're resupplying electrolytes.
And, you know, it depends on the definition of this.
So typically, if a person is doing soda 30 minutes every day,
that's not too much soda.
But even at that, anything could be too much for an individual,
depending on their weight.
And if they're in a state of Kexia and they're losing weight,
all these kind of things factor into that.
So you have to use some common sense in this.
If you are doing it three times a day and you're sweating profusely,
maybe you need to add minerals.
Some electrolytes to your diet to help supplement that.
That might be a good thing to do.
But in general, you can't really do too much soda.
Unless you're obviously overdoing it in other ways.
Okay, next question.
My oncologist said that I shouldn't take immune stimulator supplements
when doing chemotherapy.
Is this true?
No, that's not true.
The only thing that you shouldn't do when you're as far as supplement wise,
when you're doing chemotherapy.
And I would say that you shouldn't do it,
even if you're not doing chemotherapy.
It shouldn't take antioxidants,
because chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent.
That's how it kills cancer.
And if you're taking antioxidants while you're doing chemotherapy,
you're kind of negating the benefit of the chemotherapy.
And you heard me say a million times
that even if you're not doing chemotherapy,
most alternative cancer therapies are oxidative.
And if you are taking antioxidants while you're taking those,
you're negating the effects of those possibly.
So most therapies to kill cancer are going to be oxidative in nature,
not all, but most.
And all therapies to kill cancer need to have an element of immune stimulation.
So if you were taking immune stimulators while taking chemotherapy,
while doing chemotherapy,
you would only help the chemotherapy work better.
So immune stimulators are not going to counteract any alternative
or standard of care therapy.
So many times oncologists will just take this approach
that, okay, you're doing chemotherapy,
don't do anything else.
You shouldn't do anything else.
I've never heard an ecologist say you shouldn't take an immune stimulator supplements,
although you're doing chemotherapy,
that's obvious that oncologist probably doesn't even know what that means.
So I would say that you would just ignore that.
But it's certainly, I think everybody that's trying to treat cancer naturally
or even standard of care should be doing lots of things
that will stimulate their immune system.
It's only to help everything work better.
Okay, next question.
I reached five years.
And my oncologist took me off the horrible blocker at Astrosol.
I have been off it for about a week.
Should I get retested?
I think the person saying, should I get to do another cheek swamp test.
Maybe, maybe not.
So if you're on a horrible blocky therapy,
so if you have a positive ER positive or hurtful positive cancer,
typically they're going to put you on an enromatase inhibitor
that's going to block all your, your hormones.
If you reach a certain point, I mean, I'm surprised that they're taking you off after five years
because many oncologists will keep people on for ten years now.
It used to be much shorter than five years that they would keep you on.
But now, I guess the rule of thumb,
at least for that oncologist's office, is to take you off if you've got a clean meal health
at five years.
First of all, congratulations for that.
Give God the praise for healing you and keeping you in a healed state.
Now, we want to keep you in that healed state as much as possible doing our part, right?
So if you have horrible positive cancer,
and they take you off of the horrible blocker,
I would definitely go on a natural aerobotase inhibitor.
For sure.
Do we need to do a cheek swab test for them?
Not necessarily.
Honestly, I would just go on a Roma clear.
That's our most balanced or natural aerobotase inhibitor,
and I would take three of those a day, a Roma clear.
That's our private label product, and I would take three of those a day.
I don't think you need to do another cheek swab test.
Now, if you haven't done a cheek swab test forever and ever, then that's another thing.
But if you've done a cheek swab test in the last six months,
and the only change that you're making is going off and asking,
well, I would just go on a Roma clear three per day and call it good,
and we could do it on a cheek swab test after three or four months
and see if anything's changed, but you don't off that medication.
Next question.
When I take magnesium and the super allo,
I have two many bowel movements the next day.
What should I do?
So understand for those who don't know,
the super allo product is a brand name of orthomolecular,
and it is the allo, it's called the, it's called cape allo.
So it's not allo, our residents are allo, burber residents
that would be used to help stimulate immune system function.
Cape allo is used to help stimulate bowel movements.
It's a different type of allo.
That's what super allo is.
So the only reason one would take super allo is if they have issues
with bowel movements.
They have a history of constipation or something like that.
So if you are taking magnesium and super allo,
and you're having too many bowel movements,
you're in the bathroom all the next day,
then you got to admit one of them.
I would say you omit the super allo first magnesium.
The way magnesium works to help stimulate bowel movements
is it simply works by drawing water into the large intestine.
Because if you take too much magnesium,
so understand magnesium is immidial,
and it's a cofactor in about 700 different metabolic processes in your body.
It's very necessary for your body magnesium is an often overlooked deficiency
in people's lives.
Because it's a cofactor in so many metabolic processes,
it's a good idea for everybody to be taking magnesium.
How much magnesium do you need for all these metabolic processes?
Well, the truth is not very much.
Maybe only 100 milligrams.
So if you take more than that,
like some people will take 400 milligrams before they go to bed,
or 1000 milligrams before they go to bed.
That's too much.
But if they have constipation issues,
magnesium can be beneficial because if you take too much,
you don't really overdose magnesium.
You'll dump it into the small intestine or the large intestine.
And because it's an ion, it will draw water.
So it draws water into the large intestine,
and then you'll have looser bowels the next day.
So many people start taking magnesium just to help with bowel movements.
So they'll take a protocol call,
or they'll take a magnesium supplement.
Before they go to bed and they'll have nice bowel movements the next day,
and that works just fine.
But some people that are really constipated need more help than just magnesium.
So again, magnesium works by just drawing water.
So you got to make sure you're not dehydrated at the same time,
or magnesium is not going to work at all.
Secondly, still you might have issues with contraction of the intestinal muscles.
And you're taking something like superalo,
which is again, the capealo, or taking some seda, or something like that,
is necessary for some people that have a chronic constipation issues they've had for their lifetime.
But then once you start having a bowel movement,
maybe you don't need superalo anymore.
So typically I tell people to take superalo only when they need to.
Like, oh my gosh, I didn't have a bowel movement today.
I feel so bloated.
And it's now four o'clock in the afternoon.
Well, maybe tonight take a superalo with your magnesium and see how that works.
But typically, this is not always the case.
But typically people use superalo in that way.
They're only using it as needed.
And they won't be taking it on a daily basis.
Now, there are exceptions.
I have some people that have to take superalo every single day or they won't have a bowel movement.
They're not in the bathroom six times.
They just don't have a good bowel movement the next day.
They need to take it.
There's other issues, neurological issues, et cetera,
with their intestinal transit time and superalo as the thing that works for them.
But if the question is I'm taking superalo and magnesium activity bowel movements the next day,
I would omit the superalo.
See how you do with just the magnesium.
Make sure that you're drinking enough water.
And then only use the superalo as needed.
Next question.
What is the best thing to do for pain naturally without drugs?
Very common question that we get.
I don't want to take Tylenol.
I don't want to take Agville.
I don't want to take a prescription drug medication.
What can I do for naturally without drugs?
Do you use the pain program on the right?
Yes.
Does it work really well?
No.
But it can for some people.
We've had testimonies of people who said they use the pain program on the right and it worked wonders.
But that's a smaller percentage quite honestly.
The pain program is probably not going to cut severe pain from musculoskeletal pain to pain from cancer.
You're going to need something stronger.
Well, can I just take anti-inflammatory nutrients like carcubin and boswellians, stiggy nettle and things like that?
Maybe.
So we've had testimonies of people who've used betelent, which is the aloevia product that's patented from Beats.
It's an anti-inflammatory.
It had chronic pain for their whole life and it started using that two or three a day and it took their pain away.
And people use carcubin and other inflammatory flavonoids like in clear inflame and it took their pain away.
But severe pain usually is going to need something else to break the pain cycle.
And sometimes you only need to take something for a short period of time and then the other things,
these natural things that I just mentioned, may work and be a supplement for you.
But typically with cancer pain, severe pain, you're going to need something else.
Is there anything else natural that I could use? Well, not really.
Arnica is something that people have used for pain.
But again, it's not going to be the same as taking a medication that's really going to break that pain cycle.
THC, which is the psychoactive form of marijuana, can be used for pain and people have used that for chronic pain.
That can be beneficial, but it has side effects.
The side effects of THC might not be damaging one's liver, but it can make your life miserable because it makes you so loopy, you can't stand it.
So that has side effects. So it is a difficult situation to be in when you're faced with this chronic pain and you tried everything natural and nothing is touching it.
This is where I do think that God has given us medication for a purpose and can help get you through that time.
Many times you just need to break the pain cycle.
And sometimes the pain cycle is constantly ramped up because you have a tumor that's directly impacting a nerve pathway.
And that's where we might have to take more extreme measures with surgery or something like that.
But it is difficult. You know, that is a common question we get.
But I wish there was a better answer for this that pay this herb magically takes our pain away.
But for very severe pain, there's very little in that category from a natural perspective.
Next question.
Should I eat gluten-free sourdough bread with a cancer history?
And I've considered making my own sense. There's so many ingredients of the store-bought breads which I purchase regularly.
Okay, so first of all, gluten is gluten good for cancer.
Well, gluten typically is not a direct feeder of cancer.
So it's not going to be a fuel source of cancer.
So some people will say I stopped eating gluten because of my cancer.
Well, there could be a lot of good things in that statement.
But gluten is typically not going to be a direct fuel source for cancer.
Well, then why should or should a cancer patient stop eating gluten?
Well, the benefit of stop of limiting gluten is that gluten is so pro-inflammatory.
So remember, we're trying to kill cancer cells.
We don't need to be, you know, splitting our army to fight different things.
And if we are eating an inflammatory diet, which gluten would be, you know, number one on that inflammation list,
then bad oils and things like that would be in that category as well.
But if we're causing more inflammation in our gut and in our brain, it's going to be more difficult to fight cancer and kill cancer cells.
So you want to, you know, clean up your diet as best as possible so that your body can focus on what you want it to focus on.
So that being said, going gluten free as a cancer patient has its benefits.
So gluten free, even if you don't have cancer has its benefits.
Same reasons I just gave it's so gluten is so inflammatory.
But in that understanding, if I'm going to start eating gluten free foods, you're often going to get foods that are not organic.
And then you're going to get foods like this question says that you're going to get foods that have a lot of different ingredients that you don't want to be eating.
So that is an issue as well.
So you have to balance it out. What would be the best thing to do?
Well, the best thing to do would be to make your own bread if you want to eat bread.
And the other part of this question, sourdough bread has its own benefits.
So many people who are not cancer patients and are eating a gluten free diet find that they can eat gluten free sourdough bread with very little problem or much less problem that if they eat regular gluten bread.
And they start to switch over from a gluten free product to a sourdough bread.
But there if you're going to start making your own, you could make your own out of a clean gluten free flour.
And then you're solving both problems, you're not getting the gluten at all.
And you're getting a clean, you're using a clean flour, an organic flour, if you can find it, an organic gluten free flour.
The best thing would be to make your own flour with organic materials that's gluten free and then make your own sourdough start with your own culture, make your own sourdough bread.
Now, you know, obviously it sounds like you have the ability to do that.
Now the negative issue of making your own sourdough is that you're committed to making bread almost every day.
And unless you're making it as a ministry and giving it away, but it can be overwhelming for people, for the law law.
Now you can make it every day for two months and freeze it and that's another solution and then you could go off and not make it for three months.
So there's different things that you could do, but yes, could you make your own gluten free sourdough bread?
That'd be good for a person with cancer. Well, it's certainly a great option.
You're not getting the gluten and you're getting the benefits of sourdough.
So I would say yes, go for it. Stay gluten free.
Is it always on everybody's list, but on everybody's list, I put limit gluten because gluten is so inflammatory.
So that would be the last suggestion.
Okay, we got a couple questions from the chat here.
Okay, first question from the chat. I had a very general food sensitivity test done.
It showed antibodies to coffee and cow dairy.
I don't drink coffee. So how did I get antibodies? Could it be from coffee enemas?
Well, that's that question right away. Yes, you can have antibodies to different foods that come up in any test.
So understand the different tests that are out there are going to test IgG, IgA or IgE antibodies for foods.
Which that's what they'll be tested for. So those are different kinds of antibodies.
The reason why I like Syracx test for IgG and IgA are the foods plus it splits out cooked foods versus non-cooked foods.
Whether it's been studies that certain foods will be different when they're cooked versus non-cooked.
But if you had a general, you know, like you're saying, food sensitivity test and it showed positive for coffee.
How did I get antibodies to coffee if I don't drink coffee?
Let's say you didn't even ever do coffee enemas. Then how would you get antibodies to coffee?
Because some food antibodies can have molecular mimics.
So let's say you eat a lot of one thing you can actually develop antibodies to the protein and coffee,
even though you don't drink coffee because it's a molecular mimic to something else you have antibodies against.
However, in this case, if you're doing coffee enemas, yes, you're absorbing some of that caffeine and that caffeine is going to be in your gut.
So yes, you could develop antibodies because of that.
Do I need to stop them for six months to heal my gut?
Yes, if you have antibodies to coffee and you're doing coffee enemas, you might want to stop the coffee enemas.
I would say three months and retest.
I don't for for for most foods.
If you if you stop eating that food, if you have antibodies to different foods for most foods except the acceptance would be glued to the dairy.
If you stop eating that thing, you will those antibodies, most the time diminish after two to three months.
So I would say just three months and then retest again.
Though the lab might have said six months, I think you'd probably, you know, to diminish those antibodies sooner at the later.
And what can you do if you have antibodies to to coffee and you're doing coffee enemas?
Well, I want to keep doing coffee enemas. You can substitute something else for the coffee enemas.
You could do chamomile enemas that doesn't have so you're doing a tea enemas that doesn't have the caffeine.
Now the purpose of the caffeine is it's going to be a stronger stimulation of the vagal nerve in the rectal area.
But still you can get stimulation of the vagal nerve by using chamomile.
It's just not going to be as strong.
So I would just substitute chamomile enemas for a period of time.
Second question is keeper and other fermented or cultured dairy okay with antibodies to cow dairy?
Well, we don't know.
So typically when you're looking at antibodies to dairy and it says it's positive for cow dairy,
typically they're testing the protein in the dairy, which is KC.
So that's what they're testing. You have antibodies to KC.
Now will the KC be changed if it's fermented like a keeper or cultured like a yogurt?
Will it be changed? The answer is yes, it can be.
So when you do KBMO test and it only tests for cow dairy but it didn't test for kefir and it didn't test for yogurt,
well then we just don't know.
And then you're just kind of back to kind of testing things.
Many times the reason why a person did the food sensitivity test is because they had symptoms
and then they go off of the dairy and their symptoms start to diminish.
And then they would choose to really miss kefir.
I'm going to try kefir.
I'm going to go back on that for a couple days and see if my symptoms increase again.
And then if they do, I guess I can have keeper either.
And then I did wait a couple weeks and I'm going to try the yogurt.
Oh, I didn't get any symptoms with the yogurt.
So they're able to judge it by signs and symptoms whether they react to that one thing.
It's been very well documented that people have food sensitivities to dairy
and then they could eat goat's milk cheese and they don't have any troubles.
Or they could eat parmesan or hard cheese but they can't eat a soft cheese.
They can't drink milk but they can have some other form.
So the protein in these different foods can change when it's cultured,
changed, can change when they're cooked.
So it does get kind of confusing.
And even Cyrex test is still not going to be perfect.
Everybody's going to be a little different.
But if it did test positive for dairy and you really want to try to heal your gut
then the best thing is to go off all dairy for a period of time
and then slowly introduce things back when you feel like your symptoms are better
in order to be able to guide your next decisions whether that's working or not.
Okay, next question from the chat.
My breast tumor seems to be attaching more and more to the underside of my skin.
The rock hard area is getting bigger slowly.
I continue to be watchful that my body will try to expel it through the skin.
Would the wound from this be even more traumatic than the wound from a bestectomy?
So if you, if the person asking this is considering a bestectomy
because the tumor is coming closer and closer to the skin.
So first of all, what's the worst thing that can happen or let's say this.
What's worse in a breast cancer cancer case that the tumor is coming out
and it's bulging through the skin more and more palpable and getting harder
or that it's going back and attaching to the chest wall.
The answer is it's worse if it's going back and attaching to the chest wall.
So it is a better thing that it is coming out.
However, to have the tumor break through the skin and weep and bleed
it's not going to just come out like this little golf ball and be done.
So if you're considering allowing it to break through and come out and weep
instead of getting a bestectomy, I guess I would influence you
to consider a bestectomy because then you're going to remove the whole breast
and you won't be dealing with, you may have a more difficult time finding a surgeon
to do some sort of bestectomy.
If it breaks through the skin and starts weep and bleeding and causing an anemia
and having other issues then you may not even be a candidate for surgery
and that could cause other issues.
So we've had multiple women that just refuse to do surgery and let it break through
the skin and come out of the day trying to treat it topically
and it can be very messy and make your life miserable for a very long time
and then they finally decided to get a bestectomy and probably wish they would have made that decision earlier.
So at least consider that if we want to have a deeper conversation
you can feel free to make an appointment with me.
Next question from the chat.
I just received Ivermectin and got 18 milligrams for the dosage.
He said we could go higher next time.
Does this seem to be a good starting point?
No it doesn't because really your starting point for Ivermectin for cancer
should be if you take your weight in pounds and you convert it to your weight in kilograms.
So let's say you weight 100 kilograms.
I don't know how to do that just go on Google and just do conversion of pounds to kilograms.
It'll come up with a little table put in your weight and then it'll convert it to kilograms.
So let's say you weigh 100 kilograms to keep this simple.
The starting dosage for Ivermectin for cancer is 1.5 milligrams per kilogram weight.
So if you weigh 100 pounds your starting dosage really needs to be 50 kilograms.
Now you probably don't weigh 100 kilograms.
But let's say you weigh 70 kilograms.
Then your starting dosage is 70.5 of 70 which is 35 milligrams.
So the starting dosage and this is right on the member side.
So this data is you have to remember it's right on the member side the home page.
Right on the home page gives you the dosage is perfect.
Medisol in Ivermectin.
Starting dose for Ivermectin is change your weight in pounds to kilograms
divided by two. So if I weigh 70 kilograms starting dose should be 35 milligrams of Ivermectin per day.
And then you move up to, if you need, if your cancer's still growing at that over a period of several months,
then you move up to 1 milligram per kilogram.
And there's people that are going up all the way up to 2 milligrams per kilogram in very serious cases where their cancer is just continuing to grow like crazy.
So now 18 milligrams let's say you weigh 70 kilograms.
Then 35 would be your doses you just take two of those.
So you could stay with those pills you just might have to dose it accordingly.
Next question. I took fed medisol today for the first time.
I felt a little off for a few hours slightly queasy and just strange. Is this normal?
Just eat, it's best to just eat something fatty with it or right after it.
That will go away.
I mean, I have had the only time I've had people say that medisol hurt my tummy is when they first start taking it.
And then it will goes away. Eat some food with it, eat a fatty meal with it.
That's what's best. You're going to absorb it better.
It's going to have less gut problems with it.
And quite honestly, having gut problems or feeling queasy with fed medisol is not a symptom that anybody ever complains of except when they first start taking it.
Typically, they're a little nervous and so it may be coming from that.
The biggest thing that you want to look at with fed medisol, even more so that I have erected, is you want to keep an eye on your liver markers because it can affect the drug.
It can affect your AST, ALT and alcohol and phosphatase if you don't want that to go through the roof.
So we just kind of keep an eye on that.
And if your numbers are already high, we just don't want them to elevate anymore.
Next question. Actually, I just had a mild reaction to casede, high reaction to cow dairy.
I don't know what they're separating that out then.
No symptoms tested just to free up my immune system.
Well, really, you shouldn't be on any dairy anyhow for cancer because not because of the inflammatory thing.
So if you have antibodies to a food, you're going to have inflammation every time you eat that food.
So that's the reason why you would stay off of a food that you have antibodies against.
So if you're eating something that you have antibodies against, you're causing this hyperinflammatory response in your gut and in your brain every time you eat that thing.
That's why you want to stay off of it.
And how can your gut heal if you're causing a fire in the gut every time you eat?
So that's the whole purpose of doing a food sensitivity test.
Now, there's other reasons why you wouldn't want to eat certain things.
So like dairy, you'd stay away from that because you have cancer because it has so many growth factors in it.
Or gluten, you'd stay away from that if you had thyroid issues because it's a molecular mimic to your thyroid gland.
Or gluten, you'd stay away from it if you have antibodies to neural tissue, brain tissue because it's a molecular mimic to somebody like myelin, she's cells and alpha tubular cells and cerebellar cells.
So you'd stay away from that if you have any early dementia issues like that, you'd stay away from that and it's so inflammatory to your brain.
So you don't even need to do a food sensitivity test for those reasons.
So now, is there benefit to doing eating fermented dairy?
Well, there's probiotic benefit to eating fermented dairy, but you can get fermented foods without eating fermented dairy, which gives you the same probiotic benefit.
So with cancer, if your cancer is active, I would not eat dairy.
If your cancer is not active anymore and you're in a state of relative remission like me, I eat dairy again, but we don't drink, but we have a drink milk for ages.
But I do eat some cheese, and lots of times when we eat cheese, it's goat milk cheese, but it's only cheese, but not daily.
So, you know, to stay away from dairy is just inflammatory, so I don't eat it all the time like I used to, but I feel okay as far as it causing my cancer to grow because I feel like, you know, I'm in a relative state of healing right now.
So, but if my cancer, when my cancer was active, I did eat 80 dairy, so because of the growth factor issues, not because of sensitivity.
I don't have any symptoms when I eat dairy, so hope that helps.
Next question for the chat, does anyone know how to make sourdough to add to the dough to make sourdough bread?
Well, you can look that up, there's even groups, there's Facebook groups on sourdough, sourdough is really, really trendy right now because of the health benefits of sourdough.
And because people that have other issues with different bread, even in gluten free bread, they don't tend to have as many issues with sourdough bread because it can change the protein and give you got benefits.
So, it's very trendy right now and you could, you could look that up really easy. So, any other questions?
How would we know if our cancer is active or not? Would a clean mammogram tell us that?
Maybe, personally, I wouldn't do a mammogram at all anyhow because that radiation, if you had breast, obviously you're thinking of breast cancer, the radiation would not be good for breast cancer.
So, how would you know if you have breast cancer and that your cancer is active or not?
Well, you look at all sorts of different subjective and objective findings.
When your cancer, when you know, when you knew your cancer was active, how did you know that? You felt a lump, it was growing.
You went to the doctor and you had positive objective findings with your biopsy, your positive findings with your MRI or the CT scan or the PET scan.
And you decided on a course of treatment, whether that was a blend of alternative in standards or was all alternative.
And you feel like you're doing better subjectively, you don't have any signs or symptoms that you can subjectively relate to the cancer growing.
But how do I know if I'm better objectively? Well, we could go back to the scans, so it depends on how invasive one wants to be.
If we go back to the scans, that is MRIs, PET scans and CT scans, MRI typically is going to have to be done with a contrasting, which is catalytic, which can be invasive.
Some people don't detoxify and well, and I put catalytic and toxicity so long, I don't want to really do that.
The more invasive is the CT scan, which is going to give you enough radiation and about 50 chest X, right? So I don't want to do that.
Same amount of radiation with the PET scan, well, I don't really want to do that, but that's going to be your most beneficial if you're going to try to measure apples to apples.
If you did it MRI or CT scan or PET scan to diagnose it in the first place, then in order to absolutely no comparing apples to apples,
you'd have to do that same scan. Well, some people will go, yes, I want to do that because I want to know.
You have to know that it does carry, you know, inherit risk.
I'm willing to go through that risk. I need to know if I'm doing better or not doing better.
Okay, that's great. If that helps with your anxiety levels, then by all means, that's the best way is to compare apples to apples.
I do a video on this on our membership site as well. How do I know if I'm getting better? I think it's the name of the video.
But you could do other less invasive things. Do some blood work. There's ominous signs in blood work.
Are my liver markers okay? Is my calcium markers okay? Are am I developing an edemia? Oh no, I had some edemia, but that's much better.
Okay, well, you know, if things have changed for the better in standard blood work by that, I mean your CBC and comprehensive metabolic panel,
and things have changed for the better, that's a very good sign. So everything you have to take in pieces and everything is at clue to what's going on.
And then you could look at tumor marker tests. Well, I never did tumor marker tests. Well, then doing a baseline tumor marker test will be beneficial.
So with breast cancer, you do a CA153, a CA199, a CA2729, a CEA, a LDH. Those would be some tumor marker tests.
And you'd find that in our store under the female tumor marker panel.
Ready to blood sip a blood test and a tumor marker panel can give you a baseline. Let's say all of those are within normal range.
Well, we didn't know what they were before. Maybe they were high before. If this was your first one, and maybe they've come back to normal, then we would know.
So I always think it's good to get a baseline of that even if you feel like you're doing great because now you could use that. Hey, that's another indication.
My CVC is great. My complete metabolic profile is great. My tumor marker panel is great. I don't have any signs or symptoms. I can't feel the mass hasn't grown at all.
Okay, well, then I would say I'm probably gonna just claim that I'm in a state of remission of doing well.
My symptoms were worse. For me personally, my symptoms were much worse. They were really bad at one time when I was sure I wasn't gonna make it to Christmas.
And then I ended up doing a pro-novo scan, which is a different type of MRI that doesn't use a contrast die. The only negative of that is insurance doesn't cover it yet to be cash for it.
And the only negative is I think there's only seven of them in the whole United States. But I was fortunate that there wasn't what in Minneapolis. So I did the pro-novo scan.
And it just showed a few tubers in my liver that were left. And I was happy just to say, okay, God is healing me. There wasn't anything in my colorectal area when I did that scan.
Now, at the time that I did that scan, I was feeling, you know, 100 times better. I was feeling like I was, you know, you know, in remission when I did that scan.
And I have not done it again. That was, this will be four years coming up. I think, I can't remember. I lose track of time when I think back.
But it's, and I haven't had any of the symptoms again. Now, my cancer, I displayed very distinct symptoms.
It's just thinking of that today because I was talking to a different patient. I was thinking, you know, I haven't had any of those symptoms for at least four years.
So other symptoms because my body's getting old, but not those symptoms. So I've said to you guys, I've said to other people, I don't even think of my cancer anymore. I feel like I'm in complete remission.
And so I just go on with that. If God takes me home tomorrow, then I'm much better because of it. So that's okay.
So question comes in, are MRIs without contrast reliable? Well, yes and no, it depends on who you ask as far as your oncologist. It depends on also what you're comparing to.
So if I didn't MRI with contrast, I before, that's what diagnosed my cancer. If I'm doing an MRI with no contrast, I know I'm not comparing apples to apples, right?
So you're not comparing apples to oranges because it's not the exact same thing. So you can't say, wow, I'm doing so much better, because look, my end of it is visible without the contrast eye.
So taking in as many objective objective data as you possibly can and balancing that with my subjective data, how I'm feeling is the way you make that decision.
Understanding there is no, even though there is gold standard objective tests, they're often incorrect.
So you use the gold standards, but you understand that even as a gold standard, it's just giving you clues. There's people that even had biopsies that are incorrect.
Well, that's like perfect. They're taking a tissue sample and looking at it in a lamp, okay, it still could have objective failure.
So nothing is perfect. Nothing is perfect. So you take as many different objective clues as possible, balance it with your subjective clues and you come to a rational decision of where you're at and the decision-making process of what you want to do for care.
To me, that's the only way to really assess how you're doing and helping you make the decisions.
Oh, can I add this back to my diet or can I change doing so much better? Can I do this?
And there's a lot of clues that you could do from a very non-invasive blood work.
I mean, you could get a lot of clues from just doing a complete wellness panel on our site and a tumor marker panel, whether it's a male tumor marker panel or the female tumor marker panel.
So for 400, some bucks or something like that, you could get a lot of peace of mind in what you're doing. So that's what I would suggest.
Okay, I think with that, we will be to do so one more question. What's the difference between magnesium oxide and magnesium glycinerate?
So there's a whole bunch of different magnesiums on the market.
And so the magnesiums that you'd use
would be depending on what your issues are.
So if you're trying to use magnesium that would call be your brain.
Let's say your issue is you can't sleep at night and you're up a lot and you're trying to call be your brain.
There's magnesium that you might take magnesium three and eight and magnesium three and eight that would help be brain calming.
Even magnesium malate can be brain calming.
So you take that before bed. That's not technically a magnesium to help you have a bowel movement.
And magnesium glycinerate or glycinate would be a magnesium that you would take that you that would help you with a bowel movement.
Why? Because it's not as well absorbed. So it's going to have a tendency to stay in the colon and it's going to help you with a bowel movement.
Magnesium oxide is typically thought of as a poor form of magnesium.
Like the magnesium are magna clear that we have in as our private labeled magnesium.
This is cheap as the other magnesium with the benefit of it is that it has three forms of magnesium in it.
So the benefits of having multiple forms of magnesium is it can help with different things.
Now all magnesium is you know the biggest thing about magnesium is you want it to be absorbed.
So magnesium oxide is not as well. If you're trying to use it for other things that your body other than just a bowel movement.
So magnesium oxide is thought to be more poorly absorbed magnesium.
There's even magnesium carbonate very poorly absorbed magnesium.
But most of the magnesium is on the market that are mixed.
Magnesium are going to be the magnesium balance and different things that are going to be better absorbed.
So that's what typically what would be recommended.
Next question for the chat. How reliable are the two markers?
Again, there isn't any tests that's perfect. Some people will ever show positive two markers.
They'll have an extremely aggressive cancer. Some cancers don't show positive two markers.
So you know, they're like lung cancer. Let's use that as an example.
Might not show positive two markers at all.
Breast cancer typically will show positive two markers, but not always.
You know, a pancreatic cancer will typically show positive CAD 1999.
Almost always.
And colon cancers will typically show positive CEA and CA 125, but not always.
So that's that's the again, just like anything, nothing is perfect.
Question is, can I speak in a question? Yes, just unmute yourself and go right ahead.
Was this your question? Is the food sensitivity showed coffee?
And that's about caffeine? Well, again, I don't know. You'd have to actually contact the company that did the food sensitivity test.
So I don't know that the food sensitivity test that they said coffee is caffeine.
It may be something else in the coffee that they're tested and that would be a good question for them.
That is chocolate also a problem, typically chocolate and coffee are going to be measured.
I know the Cyrex tests tests for coffee and chocolate milk chocolate dark chocolate.
And they separate that out.
So I don't I don't know that it's the caffeine in the coffee that they're testing.
That would be a good question.
Because if it isn't the caffeine and it's a protein in the coffee that they're testing,
then you could actually use like a black tea in your coffee,
so you'd get the caffeine as a stimulant to the vagal nerve.
So good question, good line of thought there.
So you might want to reach out to the company and see what it is that they were testing.
Okay, so I think with that, we will say goodbye for the day.
Thanks for being on and remember to just send your questions in or just do what I love doing.
Just answer your questions like as it comes to your up it comes in your head.
All right, everybody have a blessed day and a blessed weekend.
And we'll see you next week. Bye bye.